ses voeux pour l'année 2010 est
s'adressent en premier à chacune et
chacun d'entre vous dans votre vie
personnelle professionnelle familiale
puisque c'est évidemment cela qui va
être le cadre le plus important pour ce
que vous allez ce que nous allons vivre
dans l'année qui vient ensuite ses voeux
s'adresse évidemment à notre pays à la
france qui va vivre une année cruciale
une année de choix très important et
cette année de choix elle mérite que
nous l'abordions avec une volonté que je
vais essayer de décrire en trois ou
quatre sous et le premier souhait c'est
la lucidité dans une année cruciale
comme celle là ce qui est très important
c'est que nous laissions emporté ni par
les illusions mis par les excès pour
éviter après ceux que nous connaissons
depuis si longtemps c'est à dire un
sentiment de déception
deuxièmement ce que nous devons avoir en
tête et sauvegarder plus que tout c'est
notre société de solidarité
la france c'est une société qui ne
ressemble à aucune autre
parce que nous avons voulu et que nous
voulons qu'il y ait de la tension pour
les plus faibles aussi bien que pour les
plus forts et qu'on ne favorise pas
l'effort au détriment des faibles
troisième veut c'est la vitalité du pays
on a besoin d'un pays vivant qui
inventent qui cherche qui entreprennent
qui ose tout cela qui fait que nous
allons pouvoir insuffler une dynamique
nouvelle à notre pays et enfin le
quatrième veut c'est un voeu grave et il
est international
nous allons vivre cette année dans un
monde qui est de plus en plus incertain
et risqué si l'on additionne l'élection
de monsieur trimpe aux états unis.le les
démonstrations de puissance et
d'intervention extérieure de monsieur
poutine
les choix qui sont parfois différents ou
divergents de monsieur erdogan et qu'on
pense à notre situation à nous européens
alors il faut que la france soit dans
cette année qui vient un facteur
d'indépendance et de stabilité de
stabilité et d'indépendance et ceci est
bien entendu aussi une manière de jouer
le rôle essentiel qui doit être le nôtre
en europe
voilà les voeux pour l'année voilà les
voeux pour la france et voilà les voeux
pour vous pour 2010 est très bonne année
à chacun et à chacune d'entre vous très
bonne année à notre pays